[Musique]
je me suis aussi assez discipline parce
que j'adore et l'obligé en fait je
voulais absolument un bmx
j'avais un vélo pour me déplacer qui
était pas un bmx et quand j'ai découvert
cet objet avec le double triangle
l'hérault petit à l'époque j'avais des
rois bâton et je suis tombé amoureux de
cet objet qui pour moi a ressemblé à une
petite moto pour gamin j'avais dix ans
que ça a été la rencontre d'un objet
avant la discipline
[Musique]
pour plus gros kiff et j'en ai plusieurs
le premier c'est de ride est tout seul
et inventé des figures c'est au moment
où tu concrétise un tricks que tu as
pensé et tu galères dessus des semaines
le jour il passe pas parfois c'est un
instant où tu te retrouve tout seul en
face à allonger son dos à remercier de
faire cette discipline est mon deuxième
plus gros kiff c'est gagner des coupes
et fabien ma famille qui présente j'ai
fait un podium sur une coupe du monde
avec mes enfants qui me regarde ma femme
est de les prendre dans mes bras
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mes futurs objectifs c'est de déchirer
la championne du monde déchiré la coupe
du monde de finir sur le podium et
continuer à développer cette académie
faire grossir ma discipline